are you ready for Kanye 2020 for the
rapper saying he's ready to run when I
run for president 2024 we were going to
definitely know which I laughing her
when I run for president 2024 we would
have created so many jobs that I back of
the run I'm a walk
Kanye also saying he could change his
name to Christian genius billionaire so
one what do you think about that wait a
minute wait a minute Christian genius
wait he can't he can't mimic Trump well
that's not allowed
look I look let me just tell you
something he's not gonna run I don't
think so I mean the moment you declare
half the country doesn't like that's why
Oprah and other celebrities don't run
the second point to be made here is when
you run you really have to have a fire
in your belly I mean you really have to
want it you can't just get out there and
like how he gave that steer to the
audience when they said that said you
gotta know you gotta love them and they
engaged the audience you know Ronald
Reagan when Ronald Reagan ran it wasn't
like he was a celebrity who just ran
guess what happened Ronald Reagan was
governor California he had run for
president twice before he ran
so you gotta put up with all I don't see
come on this is the same argument that
we did against Trump and I'm one of the
people who made that argument I was
talking about how Reagan did that Reagan
was an actor true but you know and he
did it but like and I honestly don't
think Trump thought he was going to win
when he was gonna win I do believe that
big that Trump has opened the door for
Kanye persuasion is now more important
than politics I I see this wherever I
like I look at people in a different way
it's like that cursed person could do it
that person can't he's I think he's a
master persuader he's he has the art of
being memorable and saying the right
I'll give it this way would Trump got on
stage everybody kind of faded imagine
him on a stage Kanye versus Bernie in
and the other thing is like I've admired
him for him he's declared himself a
Christian he's done an entire album
about it he is living his faith and it's
not easy to talk about your faith
because then you start getting attacked
from other people the other thing I love
about it is that he says the new Yeezy
sneaker it's going to be made in Cody
Wyoming and they're moving up there the
headquarters to Cody Wyoming and I think
they'll make great shoes there yeah I
think the secret weapon is Kim
Kardashian oh is that someone that say
they're gonna be the first lady yeah
think about it so Kris Jenner is
probably pulling the puppet strings here
she's got this whole thing figured out I
think it's he is a phenom and if he
actually does declare absolutely they
will win here is why so we heard part of
his platform already he talked about an
eco-conscious fashion line that he would
bring all of his jobs to North America
to South America think about his
commitment through his wife to the
criminal justice reform think about his
messaging for people of color that
basically say you're not on mas voting
bloc like you are unique there the
amount of capital they have between the
two of them just on the table alone 610
million dollar like he anything they put
their mind to they can do